I think employment coordinator,
and I'm going to let you know why --
because I work at Intel.
It's a very agile and dynamic company,
and we go through something called a "reorg,"
the joke is every year,
but, you know, every one to three years.
Even when you have a stable corporate job
within the company,
you get shuffled around a lot,
and, you know, there's always this,
"I don't think it's done very well."
They always ask you for an assessment of skills,
et cetera, et cetera,
and then they try to reshuffle groups
and make agile teams.
So, even within companies,
people are trying to make agile teams.
And I see this as a continuing trend,
and I think in the future,
people are going to be more like consultants,
that you're going to,
I see a trend towards people
wanting to own their own branch,
to own their employability
(in fact, that's a mantra,
"Everyone own your own employability")
and to see themselves as entrepreneurs.
And I think that we will all have agents,
and I think there will be agents within large companies,
and I think there will be agents
between small companies.
So, I think that people who know people
and get them optimally placed in the right jobs,
I think that's going to be an efficiency builder
for productivity worldwide.
People will have agents.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.